hola a todos de lo que quiero hablar en
este vídeo es cómo interpretar la
derivada direccional en términos de
gráficas verdad aquí tengo la gráfica de
una función de una función multi
variable y esta función de hecho es
de x tienen dos entradas verdad y ésta
se calcula como x cuadrada por y muy
bien y en los últimos vídeos hemos
hablado de cómo es que se puede calcular
la derivada direccional verdad como
podríamos definirla formalmente de hecho
podríamos calcularla utilizando el
gradiente verdad y generalmente lo que
tenemos es digamos alguna especie de
vector vamos a poner aquí un vector b un
vector b y este vector b digamos que es
el menos 11 vamos a poner el 1-1 mejor
vamos a poner el vector 11 muy bien
tenemos ese vector en el espacio de
entradas así que en este caso por
supuesto sería el plano xy y en este
caso simplemente vamos a tomar este
vector muy bien y la derivada
direccional que denotamos utilizando
digamos también como el símbolo de
gradiente pero le ponemos un subíndice
con este vector de verdad para indicar
que es en esa dirección la derivada
direccional de nuestra función
efe
en el punto x de verdad así es como la
denotamos y este es digamos una medida
de cómo cambia la función cuando nos
movemos en el espacio de entradas en
esta dirección del vector b así que te
voy a mostrar qué es lo que significa
podríamos imaginar que cortamos esta
gráfica con alguna especie de plano que
no necesariamente tiene que ser paralelo
a alguno de los ejes x oye verdad que
fue lo que hicimos cuando tomábamos
derivadas parciales tomábamos planos que
estaban representados por valores
constantes de x o valores constantes de
y en este caso va a ser un plano que de
alguna forma nos dice digamos el
movimiento en la dirección del vector
que tenemos y como lo hemos hecho en
otras ocasiones vamos a acortar nuestra
gráfica a lo largo de este plano y para
hacer claro esto vamos a colorear
digamos la la parte en donde la gráfica
intersec a digamos a nuestro plano
verdad y este vector de aquí este
pequeño vector de podríamos pensar lo
que vive en el plano xy y está
determinando la dirección de este plano
con el que estamos cortando
de verdad entonces en el plano x y
tenemos este vector que es el 11 y
digamos apunta digamos en esta dirección
diagonal verdad y tomamos todo el plano
cortamos nuestra gráfica ok entonces
queremos interpretar la derivada
direccional aquí y vamos a tratar de
hacerlo en algún valor particular así
que digamos que lo queremos hacer en el
menos uno menos uno así que hagámoslo en
ese punto en el menos uno menos uno
y mejor pongamos menos 1 menos 1 muy
bien hagámoslo en ese punto y digamos
con esta combinación de este punto y
este vector al menos nos aseguramos de
que nuestro plan no pasa por el origen
verdad así que estamos garantizando que
este plano está en el origen o pasa por
el origen y pero si no fuera así
podríamos imaginar digamos otro plano
digamos que a lo mejor tenga la misma
dirección es decir sea paralelo a éste
pero habría que recorrerlo en alguna
dirección pero bueno con esto basta para
este vídeo verdad y si hacemos esto
podríamos interpretar la derivada
direccional como una pendiente pero
tenemos que ser muy cuidadosos porque si
queremos interpretar esto como una
pendiente entonces necesitamos tomar un
vector b que sea unitario es decir que
la la magnitud o la norma oa veces
también se le llama módulo verdad la
magnitud de nuestro vector tiene que ser
1 es decir es unitario y bueno en
principio no podría tomarse vectores que
no sean unitarios verdad pero tenemos
que ser cuidar
para poder interpretar esto como
pendientes de que sí lo sean verdad en
este caso nuestro vector b no es
unitario el vector que tendríamos que
tomar
digamos que apunte en la misma dirección
pero que tenga una magnitud unitaria
verdad sería el vector raíz de 2 entre 2
raíz de 2 entre 2 y tú podrías deducir
que es este vector simplemente digamos
usando el teorema de pitágoras o algo de
ese estilo verdad ahora sí estamos
evaluando en este punto en el menos uno
menos uno verdad podríamos dibujarlo en
la gráfica verdad para ver dónde se
encuentra y en este caso digamos vamos
vamos a mover todo esto teníamos este
punto verdad que si lo vemos desde
arriba podemos ver que es el menos uno
menos uno verdad y si queremos saber la
pendiente en ese punto verdad estaríamos
pensando en esta línea tangente qué
estamos pintando es la línea tangente a
la curva y estamos digamos
preguntándonos qué pendiente tiene en
ese punto
otra anotación que podría ser digamos
útil para entender la derivada
direccional es por ejemplo esto que
utilizan algunas personas que lo
escriben como la parcial de f con
respecto a nuestro vector de verdad y
que en realidad podríamos pensar como si
estamos tomando un pequeño cambio en la
dirección del vector de verdad así que
esto sería un pequeño empujoncito en la
dirección del vector b y eso nos da un
aumento digamos parcial en la dirección
de b y cuando decimos bueno como cambio
el valor de la función digamos que
tenemos entonces podemos ver la altura
de la gráfica verdad y ahí podemos ver
ese cambio así que cuando nuestro cambio
inicial se aproxima a 0 y por lo tanto
nuestro resultado digamos nuestro cambio
resultante en la función también se
aproxima a 0 entonces lo que tenemos que
hacer es calcular la proporción verdad
la proporción del cambio de la función
con respecto al
y al cambio de nuestro movimiento en la
dirección de verdad y eso nos va a dar
la pendiente de esta línea tangente
conceptualmente esto es digamos una muy
buena anotación pero la razón por la
cual utilizamos la otra anotación donde
utilizamos digamos un habla con
subíndice b verdad es muy indicativo de
esta anotación es muy indicativa de cómo
calculamos todo verdad entonces esta en
realidad esto en realidad se calcula
como el gradiente de nuestra función y
hacemos el producto punto por el vector
verdad así que vamos a hacer de hecho
este este cálculo con todo lo que ya
tenemos verdad vamos a calcularlo de
este lado con otro color
vamos a utilizar un color verde entonces
calculemos el gradiente de nuestra
función f
el gradiente de nuestra función f es el
vector que tiene las derivadas parciales
aquí estaría la derivada parcial con
respecto a x y la derivada parcial de
nuestra función con respecto a
muy bien entonces para calcular la
derivada parcial con respecto a x
entonces x será nuestra variable y que
será una constante verdad al derivar
esto con respecto de x tendremos 2 por x
porque verdad y ahora si derivamos con
respecto de ye yé sería nuestra variable
y x cuadradas x cuadradas sería una
constante entonces tendríamos x cuadrada
pues la derivada de y simplemente es 1
ahora si nosotros evaluamos en nuestro
punto de interés que es el menos uno
menos uno verdad entonces tendremos dos
x menos uno es menos 2 x menos 1 es 2 y
finalmente tendremos x cuadrada que
sería menos 1 al cuadrado que es 1
entonces aquí tenemos ya el valor del
gradiente de la función f en el punto
que nos interesa verdad así que esto
significa que si queremos evaluar
digamos el gradiente de f por b verdad
entonces tendríamos que ir sustituyendo
esto sería el gradiente de b
el 21 y hacemos el producto punto con
nuestro vector b que tiene que ser
unitario verdad entonces sería raíz de 2
entre 2 y la otra coordenada sería raíz
de 2 entre 2 entonces al hacer esta
cuenta tendríamos que hacer el el
producto de las coordenadas verdad sería
2 por raíz de 2 entre 2 eso sólo es raíz
de 2 y 1 por raíz de 2 entre 2 sería
raíz de 2 sobre 2 entonces aquí tenemos
nuestra respuesta esta sería la
pendiente de esta curva que hemos
graficando verdad pero esto sólo
funciona si nuestro vector es un vector
unitario y ya hemos visto en el vídeo
anterior digamos cuando hablamos de la
definición formal de la derivada
direccional verdad que si nosotros
rescatamos este vector por 2 digamos
vamos a quitar todo esto vamos a quitar
todo esto aquí tenemos todo esto
entonces si nosotros consideramos la
derivada direccional pero ahora
consideramos el doble de este vector b
entonces digamos queremos calcular la
derivada direccional de la función pero
con el doble de b esto sería el
gradiente de f con él y hacemos producto
punto con dos veces nuestro vector de
verdad entonces esto nos daría lo mismo
digamos como en el producto punto
podríamos sacar las constantes sería dos
veces el gradiente de f por b por el
gradiente de f por d era justamente la
derivada dirección al original que
teníamos así que al duplicar el vector
vamos a tener el doble del valor de
nuestra derivada direccional verdad así
que va a ser el doble del valor de la
derivada dirección al original verdad
pero no necesariamente queremos esto
porque si nosotros vemos este plano
verdad con el que lo hemos cortado en
vez de ir en la dirección de denver del
vector unitario b si lo hacemos en la
dirección de dos veces el vector
es el mismo plano verdad estamos
cortando exactamente con lo mismo y que
quisiéramos que tuviéramos la misma
pendiente así que todo esto se echaría a
perder verdad esto es muy importante
cuando estamos pensando en el contexto
de las pendientes verdad otra cosa que
podríamos decir es que nuestra fórmula
para la pendiente de una gráfica en la
dirección be digamos es igual a tomar la
derivada direccional siempre y cuando
tengamos el vector unitario verdad
entonces para corregir esto simplemente
podríamos tomar el mismo producto punto
el gradiente df punto b pero tendríamos
que asegurarnos de dividir entre la
magnitud de nuestro vector b para que
entonces no haya ningún problema al
escalar nuestro vector verdad entonces
es una forma de asegurarnos de que al
tomar la derivada direccional en la
dirección de cierto vector no importa el
tamaño de ese vector verdad siempre será
la misma y de hecho algunas personas así
es como definen la derivada direccional
verdad
simplemente están normalizando la
longitud de nuestro vector ya mí en
realidad no me gusta mucho eso yo creo
que estas personas están pensando
justamente en el contexto de la
pendiente están pensando en las tasas de
cambio verdad al alser la pendiente de
esta gráfica y una cosa que quisiera
enfatizar verdad como siempre es que la
intuición gráfica es muy buena y la
intuición visual de hecho es excelente
siempre podríamos tratar de encontrar
una forma de como pensar las cosas
visualmente pero con funciones
multivariable es verdad la gráfica no es
la única forma podríamos pensar en cosas
un poquito más generales por ejemplo en
pequeños empujoncitos en una dirección
de un vector verdad y en este caso
podría ser un contexto en donde donde el
vector no necesariamente tiene una
longitud uno verdad el empujoncito no
siempre representa un tamaño real verdad
pero digamos eso es una cuestión de
escalar por una constante verdad
a ese vector así que podríamos fijarnos
en el vídeo de la definición formal para
la derivada direccional si quieres más
detalles en este tema pero lo que creo
que es algo muy bueno es tener una muy
buena intuición de lo que significa la
de la derivada direccional